Disney's live-action lad I know fans are
wondering how it will pay homage to the
original or will it be completely
different we've got those answers but
let's start with the moment from last
night's prayer where Will Smith
confessed to me that he had no idea who
Mina mossad the guy who plays Aladdin
was so what happened so we're all set
goodness dude just comes up and he's
thin he like standing in our
conversation and I'm like that's a bold
as little dancer go stand in the middle
of the director in the genies
conversation and he just stood there and
he didn't smile it was feeling like a
security situation this is big hat no
that is not will of course needed no
introduction on this set his cast mates
were more than happy to get jiggy with
the genie okay Will Smith is a big deal
in our household my brother's never been
excited about anything I've done up
until now
[Music]
both Mina and Naomi grew up watching the
animated classic but a big difference in
their remake that's their voices singing
the songs and a more empowered Jasmine
has a brand-new solo
[Music]
she's not a little bit of feminist think
she just is a feminist I think it's a
natural progression so you know it's
been 27 years since they're rich oh I
just want to make a human jasmine also
gets a new BFF who's not a tiger and a
whole new wardrobe with 9 different
outfits one of my favorites was the the
purple that was really comfortable
actually there's a dress that she wears
when she was when paintgun that yeah
that's hard that was like a 10-foot
train other changes to the live-action
Aladdin wills Genie gets a love interest
maybe it's those new muscles and we
can't help but love that the villain
Jafar went from a creepy old guy to 36
year-old Marwan concern I can make you
rich I love the fact that we have a set
range of our I mean look gorgeous my one
is gorgeous he certainly never took his
shirt off for me we trained together a
few days and I was I was aspiring to
look like that yeah he's hot yes so how
does Marwan feel about his new status as
hot Jafar your internet your viral your
an internet sensation but you're like
it's okay I'm very appreciative
[Music]